I'm gonna start from my childhood my
mother created the perfect bit because
at the age of five years old my
stepfather started trying to be
realistic
he started I don't remember really bees
this time but my mother said when when
she would come out from work because she
was 11 to 7 and he would babysit us
but she said she came home sometime and
I would be in the bed with him at the
foot of her bed with no underwear on and
she's like what are you doing in asking
me and she said you would look like so
shocked like I don't I don't know why
I'm in your bed and he would explain to
her that I got scared and I had a bad
dream or whatever and I'm with the BIA
and I can't we gotta be able to now mind
you I'm five years old I never get
scared my brother was one who was
praying in the dark he would be in my
being he was one of heating being I
would change his sheets and hiding it
but then he called closing in closet so
he wouldn't get whooping these are
things I would do for him at five to six
years old so I was a responsible one I
never so it just didn't click to me that
why wouldn't you think something was
wrong with your father with him with
your five year old child and I don't get
it I don't get it so man he only had sex
with me I think I was like nine nine ten
I don't remember for some reason I can
remember almost everything but that
specific actual event in my clinician
told me that my brain was so traumatic
that my brain would allow me to allow me
to remember but I remember having
lopsided breasts growing up and that was
because he sucked my breasts and he said
one of them mostly and I remember going
to the bathroom and
and hurry and my mother said that she
said she remembers seeing me walk bunny
around nine or ten years old and I've
always had bad bout so she thought that
I had a bad student but that wasn't the
case so these are the things that she
should have picked up on but she's
always my mother has always had some
type of addiction she's either smoked
weed pop pills I mean she so she's
always been there but not here you've
always been physically and materially
provided for but I can't remember once
hearing a cell of my brother was there
up until he became like 12 then he
started going it you can't you know all
these jails for kids and he was gone
most of the summer so I couldn't rely on
him to be there so I couldn't tell him
and I'm like forget 13 I got in trouble
I got in trouble for doing something
ditching school and I figured he'll I'm
in trouble so I might as well get him in
trouble too
so I told and she sent me to live with
my best friend who stayed around the
corner from us for the summer and when I
came back he was still there and see now
he's he's a dope man cocaine these this
is just my point of view I don't know
what's really going on with her because
I'm trying to see it from her point of
view because I have it now I have a
stepbrother that well half-brother
they had cerebral palsy so they got a
whole don't feel thing going on with him
too and my step-brother Mike and my half
brother so I'm but to me it's like
you're choosing to still stay with this
man even though you know what he did to
me
this is what I'm saying so um he told me
that if
I'm going to blame you as well that's
him mine he says it's to a
thirteen-year-old so I think about three
months later it happened again but this
time of his physical he had actually
sprained my wrist and I told her I
sprang that basketball practice so this
is a girl who got mostly basically good
grades and I played basketball I ran
track I played volleyball I got a job at
McDonald's any feelings stay after house
I just didn't want to be in the house
you know I and she was like why do you
work I'm gonna be in house I wouldn't be
houses man he's not getting so I go
through this again all the way up until
18 so I was supposed to go to college
but ignore the college I joined the
military I bring military before I
graduated high school because I was 18
and they in 12th grade so I went to see
tests and get all this and signed up and
when she found out she took me back up
there she said she can't go he still in
high school and the guy said he signed
up for they delayed Entry Program and
man she's 18 she can't go she can't even
sign herself up so everything else she
could do about it
then I told her it's another change he's
still doing it so she goes well why
didn't you tell me because I said well
when you win
I told when you told me that if it
happened again you were gonna blame me
when it happened again he told me now
you know you can't kill because she's
gonna be just as mad at you so he's
teasing that's not what I said I said if
it happens getting beat on kill I said
no that is not what you said you said if
it happens again I'm going to blame you
and 13 mom I believe what you said so I
did kick that taught me how to lie how
to manipulate and how to try to be the
person to make everything okay she
started dating my neighbor
at 15 miles 15 and I kind of looks like
last every time he pulled up on his
motorcycle she runs to the back bedroom
window plus I asked her is that her
boyfriend now and she started laughing
so instead of her she said yeah so
instead of her denying it because his
children were our friend she may leave
their go-between it's okay to give
Bridget a note to give to me or if you
want to tell me something until bridge
so now I'm gonna go between not really
in another life and manipulate so um as
an adult I view every relationship with
a man to me except for my brother mind
you was about what I can give them and
what I can do for them and and so was it
was really easy for me to fall into the
prostitution of you know and they're
being used because that's what hey
that's that's my life and people feel
fine so people would look at me and they
would say that you know we damn that's
hard but it's it's amazing how children
can adapt adapt to to the things happen
to things that happen to him because my
neighbors my neighbor's father came on
me at 13 and he gave her a hug and I was
like hmm like
oh don't you hate it when he got you
she said no that's my dad and that's
when I knew that something wasn't right
but to be like we wasn't talking about
being molested and touched in school at
that time he wasn't bringing it up I
don't know what I was told I don't even
know it was wrong until like 13 um I
knew I could kill her though so yeah my
um my life revolved around back in
running from feeling just being able to
feel my brother went when he came out
again when I was 18 that's when he blew
up because she
I literally tried to kill myself I took
a bunch of Tylenol here she my
grandmother found out all my aunts found
out and um 13 kind of covered you up and
kicked anything because my mom's the
type of person that if it looks good it
is good it looks pretty just good we had
the bestest dad me everything coming up
because she worked hard but she wanted
us to look good but we were [ __ ] up
we were up it on the inside my brothers
so my real dad he's on an alcoholic
[ __ ] at this time and he is sober I
think he I still going out like 15 or 16
years old so he's got a lot of years
sober now and he really wants me to keep
it stop the game and I think the reason
why I don't give this because I don't
think that I'm worth it my brother told
me one time he came down here for my
birthday he said we were sitting at
10:21 we eat even to me say I wish I
could fight your demons for you you
gotta fight your own demons and I wonder
what do you think you've done so bad in
your life that you feel like you need to
treat yourself like this that you
deserve to be treated like this and I
you know I'm like wow
Wow and they were like I never thought
of me like that because I wasn't made
like this I can say the big move to
today's big but I've always been in type
of person that this is I am where I am
if I feel [ __ ] up that I look like
that and my mom is always been what goes
on in this house stays in this house
that's [ __ ] because what goes on in
this house does not stay in themselves
because one of this house leaves with me
and goes with me everywhere I go like my
father told me everywhere you go there
you are so what are you running from and
I don't know I don't know because I'm
running around here like a chicken with
my head cut off like running from myself
I guess I don't know I truly truly don't
know I know that I've never different
life I've been sober I've been happy but
there's always been a man in my life
when I think so and I know now for the
past 10 years that having a man in your
life does not keep you sober and does
not make you happy my mother him in my
godbrother always told me he does not
mean you any good
this man does not love you the way you
love him I believe he does love you but
he does not love you the way you love
him and the way you deserve to be loved
and I didn't care because he loves me
enough you know because nobody else ever
give the way I thought he did or the way
he made infinity until I saw
out that I was more beneficial to him
then big when I became more beneficial
to him than the love I was like I can't
do this I can't because with me and I
love you I love you no matter what
good batter and difference it doesn't
matter doesn't matter what you do
doesn't matter how far you go we're
going balls to the walls wheels to pain
I'm going in with you or I'm gonna be
there for you and and I'm gonna accept
you for who and what you are appealing
that's if I'm ugly I don't care if
you're bisexual because if you take one
part of you away then you're not the
same person so it must be if I fell in
love with you and I find out something
about you that it must've been a part of
you then and you try to take it away
from me you're gonna be a different
person and then I mean I love you the
same way but then I don't know that's
just the way I feel that I should be
loved so that's the way I love people
and just not precipitated down here
I see that but I can't expect for people
to love me the way I love them I didn't
love them the way God expects me I have
five kids and I do not ready for my
trouble but all five of my children or
my raisable all four of them were raised
by their dad they have the same dad and
then my fifth daughter is Bruce raised
by my dad because she doesn't have your
father my first four children make
yeah they all are drug-free they all are
college-bound they all are well except
for two of them they all have kids and
they one of them is Jehovah witnessing
to Burma Mary and my 19 year olds going
to college and I'm trying to figure out
God maybe I did do the right thing by
stepping out of your life because my
mother goes well I did the right thing
because I was an addict I did my thing
because I wasn't sure off with the right
mother for him because he you raised me
since and and you can only do what you
know Mike something says I'm when you're
sober you're the best thing that could
happen to these kids and to me when you
put the [ __ ] in your mouth you turn to a
totally other person and I can be
selfish and I'd be selfish but I do
believe that I chose to deepen the New
Jersey with your family with his family
because they bring him with me and who
they're gonna be raised with me or my
family I kept seeing myself I kept
seeing inside what and I said it has to
stop and it stops
am i doing when I told her that after I
got sober
I was sober for like 22 months 21 months
and I went back to New Jersey to visit
them and they were so proud and they
told me don't you ever ever disappear
Leslie we didn't know if you were dead
or alive it was all the words didn't
care what you did because the truth came
out when you know dad it wasn't about
you doing the drugs it was about dad
sending you out to get the drugs and you
weren't here to get sent out to dig drug
he had to go be the drugs yourself then
he came back and they told me listen
sometimes her my oldest oldest daughter
said sometimes if they were talked in
their bedroom and they were saying you
know what sometimes I wish dad was dead
because if he was dead at least we're
not to worry about and then they would
say mommy the best thing she could but
by leaving us here and gonna do what she
had to do so when I showed up on
Facebook when they showed up on Facebook
and I was like here not to be the truth
and the program that I was at I had been
there for so long and let me go out of
town he let me fly to new drugs before
days and there's my family's life like
okay give it to me that was part of my
recovery plan let me let me have it
give me I'm me and I asked myself what
he never touched I mean I needed to know
and they told me no they told me oh they
remember we were and then when I was
giving them baths and I was telling
these it was so important these are your
private parts don't let anybody touch it
I mean that's kids you're coming up and
I'm teaching this and I said I don't
care who it is
whoever it is if somebody touches you
and you feel uncomfortable I'm touching
you and they won't stop tell your dad
your dad tell you it was your tell your
teacher tell somebody juggling two
crossing guard keep telling until it's
somebody
and I meant that still letting in my
children and I told my husband when I
got me play to come back here to be some
recovery and I left a new drug yes yet
but one thing I want you to do is never
tell them that they don't have a voice
never till he was shut up because it's
all my mom told me to do children are to
be seen not heard I kind of stay in the
streets but not on the streets but I
have a place that I can go and sleep
when I really really need to sleep
because the last time I slept in the
tent and I can't woke up with somebody
in my tent that wasn't in my tent when I
went to sleep
no chicks shower and I wasn't as clean
as I thought I should be and I can't
like I want to accuse him but I didn't
wake up in the middle of it I woke up
afterwards but I'm getting flashes you
know what I'm saying I'm getting flashes
of updates happening and I'm looking at
him and I'm like you're a rapist and it
mean so change for you to be a rapist in
your eyes because and he's like oh so
you're mad at me what do you mean am I
mad you yeah I'm mad at you because what
hurts me the most is that I trusted you
you know I didn't have any choice for
myself either or it might have happened
to me in the past because I kind of
thought it did sleeping on the streets
but I didn't remember it so it wasn't as
present or I didn't catch it but I
trusted you you know I called you a
friend and this is what you do
so if I picked you to be my friend then
there's something wrong with my picker
there's something wrong with me these
are the type of people that I choose to
be my friend that's what I think
so now I got to deal with it everything
comes back to me in every Detroit in
every decision that I make so I don't
know if I'm down there trying to figure
out what type of person does that
I need to be or if I don't know but I
know I'm tired I'm truly truly tired and
I think she's gotta be my last cycle
downtown display